mm gun fires prayer back and welcome to
Garry's Mod pirate ship wars I think
it's called
it's pretty funny I hope you boys are
like in the animation you're walking
around we'd like your gun like sticking
out like a [ __ ] what I'm really serious
about this mod oh now I can so
wow this is pretty cool I need you to
get on the cannons I love how there's
man walking any air son I can't see
somebody stabbed me
but hey hey crushing it oh I know I got
a bandit rated by it who's on my team
just oh sweet oh and think about Ken set
the sails for bar board something I'm
gonna capture this ship it you don't
know that you sailing lingo or I'm
sliding off I'm signing up I don't want
sword those [ __ ]
nice going minks silly party what am i
doing gherkin or am I going die judging
pirate play that hey hey hey why even
know what's going on magic going on
trust me what's happening okay listen
now the rounds gonna restart I hope they
say it's two one two you just gotta sink
the other person ship okay and what are
you doing
can I am this I am that I am the kiyose
tourist i sear man whatever okay so me
is it Oh backup
you can't kill your teammates
okay I just cut on you a little bit yep
here we go here we go god dangit red oh
you stupid air face okay we're gonna win
right now
pretty sure you can't steer this boat oh
yes use these cannons whether you press
e like that oh you press E okay cool
it's time again don't stab me we're a
team okay a team
I like the angles the cannons get a
matte like ridiculous one I changed
color if I stab you to this trigger come
haha
why are you guys killing each other
you're supposed to kill us we're gonna I
know yeah it's just like none ya have
that ship you won't let me hey never let
you yes Wow
they Pro can to play by the rules
forget it
jeez it's like you ever get gives up
alright here we go
okay let's let's okay Ken I don't we
have to use some different language so
they don't understand what are you doing
a channel sells then jumped off the boat
okay can i really
what what what happened okay can I'm
gonna can augment the can't sleep in the
man you gotta protect me yeah yeah done
for you catch the bullets for you yeah
you guys did a great job
that'd be great mingi don't shoot me
okay thank you
thanks Caleb okay ready charge the
cannons instead of we be the most
dangerous pirate all matters
okay shoot up yeah I don't like the look
of minx yeah how you like that
oh boy oh boy no you can't shoot me the
cannonballs it's against the rules kick
ah you're going down now blue team just
a bit you know just oh I drowned
oh no mutiny wait where ever
ah where where's all the action
I'm ready doc on this boat oh sauna I
can this ship killing me thanks Willa
cannons no shoot no I shot a cannon in
the cannon that's like a boot uh get
this cable
oh shoot again mix oh you you're going
down now sucka
oh please don't shoot me I'm gonna go
get it so you're gonna stop you
okay don't do any of those things that
I'm allergic to both of those okay
Phillip our vote get off our plate what
okay I'm just gonna shoot their boat I
don't understand Oh glad we live in a
world that I fog away from oh Jesus oh
thanks I killed something
double kill I'm the best pirate ever say
oh [ __ ]
you get like one shot and that's it
no can oh I got you in the cannonball
this is so intense
holy [ __ ] use these bottom cannon
Calabar Kevin ah
I'm protective in my life captain stay
away all of them let's go eat this up
okay let's kill him together I don't
like him either big Sheila with the
caddy
don't shoot anyway with the cannon
everything musky
why are you killing me I am there in a
captain bones shits out of mine I don't
care
oh you would die this is my escape
stop I'm thinking over that about now
that you can't do that stop stabbing me
you're gonna kill me you thirsty don't
move don't move oh yeah you bow them to
get off our boat it's so fun left and it
isn't a nice sound and enter I don't hey
it's cool don't worry about it it's cool
good good it's all good it's all good I
tell me Davey gangs stop [ __ ] stop
trying to stab me it's giving action but
muscat Kenny what are you doing you try
to kill me and blow the ship up that's
why I am on this [ __ ] about all their
[ __ ] much die I wish this gun would late
to not take seven years to real age
don't you dare Ken don't you even think
about it how they spent so much hours in
genetics keep going Ken ah
watch out thanks ty wait but there are
you taking us captain to go an adventure
you just kill me there is no Xplode okay
alright are you on their ship man - does
dungeon land crab off our ship walk the
plank
walk the plank and buy don't have a butt
playing with this your there's a
multiplying I'll get ya oh hello the
cannons day okay I got the can of salmon
tuna I know it yeah no no bola hey we're
thinking Ken much you say hey hold my
hand on that you only meant well
are you ruining my theme song let me
yeah I press hope you enjoyed this
effort it is we have a lot of fun
playing it there is a little Morris if
you bros one one me to upload the other
part let me know and I'll be happy to do
so anyway hit subscribe to come bro
today and I'll see in the next one say
awesome res love you you bros my looking
down on me you're normally do that well
[ __ ]
oh there's a kitchen cool